my name is Peter Bacchus
I work in Netflix before we get started
I want to kind of take a gauge of the
crowd how many folks are on the data
science data engineering infrastructure
so how many folks for data science ok
and the engineering side data
engineering or infrastructure ok cool
all right so let's go a little bit about
here we go a little bit about me as
pizza and run real time data
infrastructure at Netflix prior to
Netflix I spent time at ala Yahoo PayPal
everything from payments to behavioral
targeting to display advertising my
background is primarily distributed
systems large-scale infrastructure when
I am NOT at work I advise several
startups primarily around data security
and containers so if anyone's that a
start-up and want to talk about
something always happy to take a call or
an email and and chat about what we've
done what I've seen things of that sort
so always always happy to try to help as
any way I can all right
so Keystone Keystone is our common data
pipeline how many people here are
familiar with data pipelines and data
movement and things of that sort all
right how many people here realize
that's a very big problem that a lot of
organizations alright so the job of my
team is to essentially provide the paved
path for your data engineers and data
scientists to be able to do what they
need to do so at Netflix we have a
concept of paved path it's the way that
everyone can use a service to be able to
do what they need to without having a
building infrastructure themselves now
having said that Netflix is a culture
where
we believe in freedom and responsibility
and so if someone wants to go off-road
they're fully free to go do what they
need to do we optimize for agility and
not a slave for efficiencies so if
someone comes to me and says hey I want
you to be able to do this and it's not
on my roadmap or I can't get to it in
time they're perfectly free to go do and
build what they need to so that they can
deliver their product and their service
and the manner that they need to now
having said that when you do go
off-roading
sometimes you get stuck so what we try
to do is really build that that common
paved path for for people what I'm
hoping to talk about today I want this
to be interactive these are some things
I put down if people have questions
please ask for every question that is
asked Pete has a Netflix bottle opener
in the form of a question sir and a form
of a question you could get one so I
want to talk through the architecture
design principles that that we put in
place while we were building Keystone
some of the technologies by the end of
this it will be buzzword bingo so
there's a lot of technologies in place
but also best practices I think one of
the things I want to have people take
away is even if you're not at Netflix
scale there's certain things in certain
ways that we've done things that could
benefit people and that's you know
hopefully whether you're doing a million
events a second or 100 million it
doesn't matter there's still some
principles and best practices that that
could help okay so how many people here
know what Netflix does so you think
we're really a logging company I believe
Adrienne had a quote about us being a
logging company that occasionally
streams movies and this is true so what
does that mean that means and here's the
big numbers we process we ingest over
600 billion events every day at peak we
do 11 million a second about 24 GB
hundreds of different event types over
1.3 petabytes a day so this is daily
numbers what are these events these
events are things like session trace
annotations their business events that
we use to do things like build
recommendations things of that sort a B
test streaming client logs things of
that sort
we don't handle operational metrics so
this is purely on the application server
business events side there's another
system called Atlas that's been open
sourced that handles all the operational
metrics and so it's kind of been be
coupled between the two systems
aah-ha-ha so we process over a trillion
events every day this handled in our
around service we also hit a trillion
events ingested these are all unique
events during the holiday season so
while everyone was home over the
holidays watching Netflix not spending
time with families we were at about a
trillion events so now if you notice
we've gone down and I'll talk a little
bit about that here in a little bit well
it's great to stand up here and say look
we do a trillion events and we can check
that off our philosophy is really we
want them to be useful right so
producing an event for the sake of a
person event doesn't do anything decide
put like really big numbers on so as
data scientists as the engineers you
know people talk about big data and fast
data it's really useful data that that
we want Sal
so at this point I want to take a step
back and talk about where we were about
a year ago a little bit over a year ago
and why we made some of the decisions to
move to Keystone and build Keystone so
originally our data pipeline looked like
this very simple we had events being
produced and collected ask a question
and you get a bottle of it based on a
patch each aqua
so essentially application services and
publish events we'd collect on we'd
write them to s3 for all our offline
processing so very simple great things
work great people were very happy until
they weren't so a little bit after that
people started wanting to have the
ability to do things like at least once
real time and so we created introduced a
branch off mainline that's he traffic
into Kafka we routed it to elastic surge
and secondary kafka clusters were then
it was consumed by either consumer
applique purpose-built applications
spark mantis mantises are open source
it's not open source yet it's our
in-house stream processing system that
we have so that's can conceptually where
people consume either from this Kafka or
that Kafka
the problem that we found is there's a
lot of duplication if you notice there's
a lot of functionality that's very
similar it also confused a lot of people
so producer to come and say hey I want
to produce an event do I send it through
here do I send it through there what
happens if I need guarantees and so
about a year ago we decided we wanted to
be able to simplify what we had and be
able to start offering higher level
services so as we looked at this we said
okay well we need to be able to do at
least once people want to be able to do
things in real time so we could invest
and build things ourselves or we can
look at what's out there what parts of
our infrastructure
provide some of this functionality is
there a community behind it and what can
we do and so what we decided on was this
so if you look at this pipeline it's
much simpler we've essentially flattened
out what we had before so we removed
chakra we put a fronting kafka so
essentially handle the fan in handle a
fan out the routing service is different
that's enough I'll talk about that in a
minute
so when we were looking at the routing
service you know as we're adding in
durability and at least once if our
routing service was not able to provide
the same semantics an SLA is it served
no purpose and so we ended up using
Sam's and I'll talk about the routing
service and what that looks like but the
primary point of doing this was well
being a snowflake is awesome common core
infrastructure is not that different and
what we want as a team is to innovate
where we can provide additional value to
the business so when we looked at Kafka
versus what we were doing at least once
had durability had a huge community
behind it and so we decided that our
effort was better spent getting Kafka to
where we needed it to be versus writing
it completely over ourselves now having
said that there are challenges Kafka was
designed to run in a physical data
center running an AWS there's different
challenges that after you have to adjust
with but for us it was better to try to
solve those problems than to be the only
company that had something that no one
else was using and we had to support the
entire thing ourselves folks here know
Kafka okay all right so I'll skip
through this stuff unless someone's
curious about Kafka we could talk about
it afterwards there's a lot of great
material out there that people could
read up on
so common terminology you'll hear
producer-consumer topics partition
brokers this is a very if you google
Kafka you'll probably see this alright
so one of the things that we do
differently is we don't use just a stock
Kafka producer what we've done is we've
put a wrapper around the copy producer
for a couple reasons for us right now
it's best out for delivery
we prefer dropped and block so our
philosophy is we should never block an
application because we the point of our
service is to stream movies and so that
is the important piece so if an
application or service needs to do their
function and be blocking the ability to
send an event that's bad
so we our philosophy is drop not block
the other part is integration into our
ecosystem so like eureka atlas things of
that sort so for those who have used
netflix so open source software or know
about it we have a ton of stuff that
we've built and so it's a lot of
integration into our services as I
talked about philosophy is not to block
so if we have an outage the existing
application should be able to perform
their function so if that's doing
playback of a movie they should be able
to do that because they can't send an
event should not mean that your
experience is any worse at the same time
if all of a sudden we get I need to
scale up or launch new instances because
our service is not available does not
mean that your service should suffer you
should be able to operate your service
in the way that you need to the other
one is once we restore service it
shouldn't require you guys and do
anything your application should be able
to start sending events again just like
normal without requiring any action
so we provide a buffer on the client
side and I'll talk about this a little
bit later on but once you fill that
buffer it'll start dropping messages and
so that's there you go you really wanted
that it's nice isn't it yes was that
yeah yeah
so in general our our philosophy is like
I said it's we should not block like any
other services having said that one of
the questions that we are talking about
right now is the value of data not
because not all data is created the same
and so there are certain events that we
don't want to drop and so now how do you
create a different class of service to
ensure that those events go through
versus other ones and so those when I
talk about higher level services and
what we offer that's the stuff that
we're talking about psych-k data's not
all created equal what does it look like
do these events do we need to have
multiple copies of this do we need to
guarantee do we need to provide quotas
so that since it's a multi-tenant system
if you're behaving poorly it doesn't
affect someone else and those are kind
of the some of the questions that we're
starting to have right now
what are we partition it so right now
what we're doing is we have each event
type is a topic and then based on volume
will partition across now part of it is
we need to make sure that clusters are
balanced because otherwise what you'll
do is you start seeing some interesting
behaviors but that's that's kind of what
we do there's some work that's being
done on automatic rebalancing and things
of that sort
that'll be coming out but yeah the
question yeah I mean so that's we're
doing so this is v1 of the new pipeline
but there are a lot of conversations
around you know retries and what does
that look like what do we what signals
we provide back to the application so
right now we assume a lot of the
responsibility as a service what we want
to do is we wanna provide signals back
to the apps so they can decide what they
do with it you could decide on your own
this is really important I want to do a
retry or I want to write it temporarily
somewhere else and then send it or I
could say you know what this isn't an
important message I'm gonna drop it but
we don't have the ability right now but
that is that is work that we're looking
at doing so we have suite control
libraries so we could we could see what
sent versus what we ingest
No
we'll get to it so your buffer question
right here see so we drop when we float
buffer the other thing that we do is we
do only one act instead of two we don't
want to wait for that second act in case
that takes well we don't want to block
on it so we're willing to lose a message
rather than wait for two acts now having
said that as we start looking at a
higher quality service there may be
situations that that we do that so all
right
sticky partitioning we batch when we
produce events primarily we want to be
able to reduce burden on CPU and network
yes
yeah I mean part of it is you could do
things like you could write to disk you
could I mean there's other things you
can do
temporarily to weather situation what
we've designed for is on the producing
side and our biggest challenge right now
is around the producer and drop-in
events especially as we're running at
scale once you start getting replication
lags things of that sort you have
brokers that are misbehaving and so we
don't have a huge buffer because we
don't want to have you know take up a
huge amount of memory for all
applications so I mean there's a couple
of things we could talk about some of
the strategies that we're looking at and
depending on what events you're doing
and things of that sort
retries and things of that but we could
if you want afterwards I'm happy to like
so for like deep questions happy to go
in after so we talked about batching so
how do you produce events using platform
library it's a log event as an
attainable we also provide so Netflix is
primarily a Java shop but there are
other other languages that are around
and we're starting to come more polygons
we do provide a proxy service so if
you're running Python or something else
you can access your service the same
thing with the with a sidecar we inject
metadata so gooood timestamp host app in
general we have our own wire protocol
it's really it's invisible to source and
sinks we currently support JSON with
Avro on the horizon so that's kind of
legacy of where we were and so in our
migration from the old pipeline into the
new we wanted to minimize the moving
pieces and so this actually did cause a
little bit of an issue so we had the old
pipeline running
we essentially shadow traffic onto the
new one as we were building it out and
when we changed our wire protocol we
actually introduced compatibility issues
downstream and so in hindsight this is
one of the ones if you're doing a
massive migration try to minimize the
number of moving pieces and make it as
simple as possible
this probably added you know weeks to
our timeline because we had to go back
and validate because now we got to
introduce a change and we did it for the
right reasons but in hindsight like I
said it's one of those things where it's
like okay if you could minimize get from
existing legacy on to new and then
iterate afterwards having said that the
entire process was about a year and so
we ran from where we kicked it off to
end alas here where we cut it over so
you know as I talked about 600 billion
events or whatever we were actually
doing 1.2 trillion because we were
shadowing both so so we haven't so Park
a is 4 so we do use Park a but that's on
the HDFS I so we'll have to actually
translate we'll have to transform from
Avro to parque so what we do is as a
sequence files that we deliver to s3 for
EMR for all the Hadoop stuff they use
parque so but I'll go into like that's a
highly contested conversation at Netflix
right now but I'll talk more about that
and anyone who's interested in Avro
versus anything else like proto before
we could go into that so we did packages
as a jar primarily because we wanted to
be able to evolve it independently
it is fairly lightweight we don't add a
lot of size to each event the other
thing that we have from legacy is a 10
MB size on
it's a pretty big event we are trying to
move down to supporting probably a one
bag but this is one of those things
where we decided not to introduce
changes that our producing apps would
have to do okay so that's where you have
to sue it's very batchi so typically
what happens there it's not a constant
steady stream is the app that's sending
it is in there and it'll batch to that
size and then send but it makes it a
little bit more complicated as far as
now balancing what your bytes n are and
things of that sort and whatnot and part
of it is our philosophy our average
payload size is a couple K and so to be
an order of magnitude so that's so those
are conversations that we have to have
with the team they have good reasons for
doing it but you know one of things
we've talked about is like okay well
what if you write that to s3 and then
just send a location through our
pipeline and then your app can pick it
up afterwards so we're trying to work
with those teams but ultimately we want
to drive that down about one mag like I
said one especially given our average
payload size I think that's four that's
it's fair
yes
yeah so what will happen is you it will
drain what's in the buffer so what'll
happen is you'll fill up the buffer all
the other messages drop it comes back up
what's in buffer will get flushed and
then they'll start producing so we've
provisioned for peak plus so part of it
the challenge that we have is being a
stateful service we we don't necessarily
have the ability to auto scale yet we're
working on that scale e MEPs a little
bit easier but we've had to provision
for p+ failover and so while it is
possible we haven't seen that so and
usually what will happen is we won't
lose like everything it'll be isolated
I'll talk a little bit about the
fronting Kafka and the purpose that it
serves so if you look at the
architecture we have fronting Kafka and
the sole purpose is to essentially
create a buffer to be able to sustain
all incoming requests so that's like
said provision for peak Plus failover so
from a failover perspective if we fail
out of a region will shift traffic and
so we've calculated what that is and we
provision for that and we have the
ability to add additional partitions and
things of that sort but now if we do get
overwhelmed once again the intent is to
drop what we've done here is we've
actually it's not one cluster it's eight
clusters per region so we run eight
clusters per region so we have 24 on the
fronting side we've also isolated on the
zookeeper side so each cluster has his
own zookeeper cluster so the reason why
we ended up doing that is we did have a
situation where a zookeeper leader
reelection caused some interesting
behaviors and at the time we were
running four clusters something like 14
or 15 thousand partitions and one of
them and those clusters just weren't
able to recover after that
re-election and so what we decided at
that point is to minimize our blast
radius we split it up into smaller
clusters and so now we kind of max out
how many partitions and if we need will
just add new ones and each of those
clusters have their own zookeeper so we
try to keep it under 200 nodes per per
cluster and partitions probably around
10,000 so yeah I mean we'll get into
that it's it's a it was a long night and
I'm yeah so we could talk about that
issue and a lot of the network things
that we're seeing especially being in a
cloud so we're so for folks out there
were easy to classic most everyone not
here that in Amazon's probably VPC will
be migrating to V PC this year and we
should get a lot better network
performance and so like that's for us
that that's that's a big incentive but
yeah I'll go into details about what
happened and why it was a long night and
yeah so in addition to those eight
clusters what we do now is we have two
priorities normal and high pretty
complex stuff a so as I mentioned the
fronting Kafka is a buffer and what
we've done is based on priority we have
a retention period of 8 hours to 24
hours what this does is it allows us if
we have a downstream of that if
something's going on with s3 or we have
some back pressure with elastic surge or
something happens with the routing
service it allows us that long to be
able to handle in ich an incident
without losing messages and so you know
we do two copies eight hours and 24 we
are going to offer the ability to select
one two or three copies depending on
priority what we want to do is we want
to push a lot of what we're doing now
down to one copy like I said it's what's
the value of data right there are
certain things where we want to make
sure you don't lose there's others where
some loss it's okay and so as we're
going through and looking at things like
cost attribution and the value of events
and whatnot we want to be able to split
that out to start with we went with two
copies billion versus error logs
password changes versus a sign up versus
someone doing a trace on their service
so and there's other things that we then
used for recommendations or a/b tests so
you don't want to lose certain events
cuz now that makes skew your results for
an a/b test and all of a sudden you're
getting recommendations that you're like
what so so that's kind of an evolving
piece so we'll see we'll see how it goes
before we go to one copy there's a lot
of producer improvements that we need to
make right now where we lose the
majority of our events and by loss we're
talking you know point zero zero zero
one per side but it's it's at from the
producer to the broker so size wise we
have over 3,000 million
3,000 brokers that we run for Kafka
that's spread across three regions
multiple ACS within each of those
regions we are using d2 Excel
for us it was a balance between
performance and cost those were those
are newer instance types but but yeah
that's kind of the footprint there we do
do replication assignments that are zone
aware and this has some benefits for us
around availability so if we lose an AZ
it's okay we still have other a Z's
where data is distributed so we don't
have loss we also can sustain a host
failure so if you have a host that has
multiple instances on it we're still
okay an added benefit of us being able
to do this is around cost of maintenance
we now have the ability to remove an
entire AZ upgrade perform any
maintenance and add it back in and so
that was kind of a nice side effect of
us gearing for a higher availability was
that no so we have the ability it's like
said it's it's seamless to our customers
they don't they don't know the
difference we also have I guess I could
talk about this as we good so part of
our failover strategy is in region so we
have the ability to spin up a new
cluster shift traffic there do whatever
so if we have a cluster that's having
problems we can essentially just route
traffic to a new stand in cluster
resolve it blow it away whatever and
then once once the resolved shift it
back so we have that it's all automated
so if there's loss that's happening we
have very tight SL A's as far as how
much data we could lose and so if
something's happening we'll spin up
route there is a time that it takes to
probe a little provision that also has
its own
keeper clusterer that we use however its
shared amongst all the failover clusters
so each of the eight clusters has their
own and there's an additional ninth one
that if we have to fail over any of the
other clusters that would use a shared
one but we figured from a risk
perspective we're okay with that
so that's that's one of the things that
we've worked on over the past few months
is the ability to seamlessly do in
region fail overs and whatnot one of the
services that we have is an auditor
kafka auditor there's actually really
really useful for us we will be open
sourcing this over probably the next few
months hopefully a little bit before
that but it does provide us broker
monitoring consumer does heart beating
we could do performance metrics with it
it's a standalone service so we'll be
open sourcing that and it's a lot of the
things that we use to see the health of
our system we use our auditor for
current issues as I mentioned trade-off
between cost and performance using the
db2 excels we've noticed that our
performance does curate the more
partitions we have and so we try to
limit so what we could do top at
migrations so we have the ability to
automatically migrate topics over and
seamless as far as loss for customers
and whatnot and we also see a
replication lag so one of the things
that we're interested in with one copy
is to see if our drops actually go down
because we no longer have that
replication lag that's causing some
anomaly within that broker that's been
trying to be written to routing service
any other questions
so the the problems that we had with the
d2 xl's were they were new and initially
a lot of the placement so we had one
physical host that had a lot of
instances and so if something happens to
that it would actually we'd see large
amounts of brokers going offline the
density has gotten a lot better and the
placements gotten a lot better I am
interested to see how it is in B PC the
one things that we're looking at is
actually going with a lot larger
instance type so we'd go fewer but we'd
have more and so we wouldn't have the
noisy neighbor so some of the times we
see some of that pop up also we have
looked at other instance types we're
starting experiment little bit with EBS
as well to see what that looks like
preliminary results seem pretty good so
there's a lot of performance
improvements that we're looking at over
probably the next few months and you
know from instance types to kind of
storage we're using things of that sort
and part of it is if we can now start
saying we need less or less or retention
or have you know more network bandwidth
we can start playing with some of those
configurations but for us the d2 s from
a cost performance kind of blinded was
kind of in the middle and so so we
worked out a lot of stuff amazon's been
great with that so they worked with us
really closely early on as far as I
trouble shouldn what the issues were and
whatnot so Amazon has been a great
partner for us in that sense yes
nope we're all in
all right so I'll do a little dance well
you think about the other one so we have
a lot of in-house built tools so the one
area for those who are using Kafka
there's a lot of things that we've built
were we're focused and I'll talk about
this later
around self-service these are just
common things that everyone has to do
whether to manage our environment or how
you do you know topic creation and
things of that sort so if anyone's
interested in collaborating like please
reach out to me the one thing that my
team is passionate about is working both
internally externally to try to solve
these problems like I said we're not
we're not a snowflake
the reason why we chose to go with
something that has the community is
because it has a big community and
granted some of the challenges that we
have due to scale other people don't
have but how you manage Kafka like
whether it's ten nodes or three thousand
you still have to manage it so if people
are interested are doing stuff glad to
collaborate so did you remember that I
did I stall enough all right
yeah so we in general we routinely fail
out of regions as a company we do
exercises all the time where we'll shift
traffic around
we run Cass monkey on brokers they die
all the time one of the reasons we went
to an isolated zookeeper is because we
didn't necessarily want our blast radius
so I mean we have leader election
happens all the time and the most part
it works fine but part of it for us is
risk mitigation but you know I talked
about her failover strategy we routinely
practice it so just having the
conversation this morning with my team
first thing that on-call does is
failover a cluster because then you know
it works so every time every week where
someone's new like we failover at least
once a week and that's just how like we
know things are gonna fail the question
is how fast can we react how do we
mitigate the risk
what's a blast radius how do we
communicate to our upstream and
downstream partners
what's our SLA like what visibility do
we have and so so yeah I mean it mean we
have a small team it's nine engineers so
and most folks are relatively new to the
team over the past year we built the
team out but the way we test failure in
the way we automate it's the only way
we're able to manage something of this
scale is through automation and there's
a lot of effort being placed in
self-healing systems so if a broker
something's going on with a broker we'll
just kill it and replace it right
because we have a very tight SLA and so
being able to detect those signals and
instrument things in such a way that if
this happens automatically just kill it
bring up a new one so that's a lot of
effort that we've put in especially over
the latter part of the year to try to
productionize things so that when
failures do happen like the big one we
had were able to react and
mitigate what the risk is to the
business this we are so Kafka we're not
or routing service we are so if you look
at great segue you should get two bottle
openers so our routing service based on
Samsa care I'll go a little bit about a
topic most people sound like you're
familiar with Kafka and topics and
things of that sort so docker my sequel
Samsa and checkpointing cluster so we
did a significant amount of work to
Samsa to be able to run it in standalone
we run it in containers we use my sequel
to be our system of truth so the way our
routing service works is you have jobs
that are signed partitions and their job
is to read those and move them to
whichever sinks so it's a per per topic
per sink we run in containers it is a
fairly simple overall service but very
complex SLA around what happens how do
you launch and what not we do have the
ability to auto scale or a routing
service and so if you look at what we're
doing we're running about 13,000
containers in production about 1300
hosts we actually had less containers
more hosts we've done some optimizations
over the past month part of that is as
we were rolling out our service our
focus was on being able to move from old
service on to new knowing that we could
do performance improvements and minimize
some of the spend and whatnot but yeah
so we're we're up to thirteen thousand
containers most of them are fairly
similar they handle between 1 and 12
partitions we pack across a box fairly
consistently we don't have a need for
any complex scheduling
because her jobs are very much
long-running the breakdown is 7,000 4s3
so that's all the offline Hadoop piece
we have 4500 ish in Kafka and another
1,500 for elasticsearch the thing that's
interesting is that's about a 55/45
split when we first started so when I
started Netflix a year and a half ago we
were only doing about 15 to 20 percent
on the real-time branch so what's
happening is we're starting to see a lot
more workloads and a lot more desire to
do things in real time we've seen a huge
explosion and the number of
elasticsearch clusters that are running
the nodes and like I said it's you start
to see a lot more folks interested in
the real time piece one of the things
that we're doing on the self-service
perspective is giving people the ability
to also determine not only their quality
service but their destination so it
becomes opt-in so right now everything
ends up in s3 whether we want it or not
there are certain events that we really
just we really want to process them
right now and after that it doesn't
matter but by default everything and
that's kind of a from a legacy if you
looked at the original pipeline it was
that was the sync
yeah
so technically we don't need to run in
containers so our routing service is the
start of our stream processing offering
and while routing service is very fixed
as far as resources we know what it
looks like when you're doing general
stream processing you may have a huge
difference in workloads and so we want
to we want to have the ability to offer
people to be able to do different
workloads along you know across a shared
infrastructure and so for the routing
service itself it was an investment in
where we're going
versus where we're at does that make
sense yeah something we have it and it
so part of it is if you start looking at
the ability to manage resources across
so eventually what we run here there'll
be other workloads not just processing
workloads and so the ability to do
resource management and appropriately
and then use your peaks and troughs you
become a lot more efficient also kind of
the isolation and whatnot we could for
this for all intents and purposes we
could have you know ran it and spun of
VMs for it but for us it was an
investment into where we're going versus
doing something temporarily and then
having to redo it down the road so yeah
I mean for routing it wasn't necessary
five five all right more numbers more
numbers people I'll post this up people
can grab it as I talked about we have
isolation per job per se so each job
reads
from a topic certain number of
partitions and it'll write it to the
appropriate destination
I'll get your question after since we
have five minutes a couple things there
the isolation is good we used one of the
problems we had before was we had a
routing job that would write some
multiple sinks and so if you're getting
back pressure coming up from
elasticsearch it would then cause other
jobs to back up as well and so from an
availability from a balance perspective
we and I'm splitting those out see talk
about at least once so our intent is to
offer at least once we once events get
into Kafka we have pretty good ability
to do that however as I mentioned our
biggest issue right now is from producer
to broker we are putting a lot of work
into it
the 0.9 release helps out a lot so we're
currently in process of upgrading to 0.9
we're we have the test environment we're
evaluating and we'll be doing that so
hopefully that should solve some of the
problems that we have data loss we
touched on basically buffer full network
errors so from a Kafka perspective the
ability to be spread across multiple
AZ's allows us to mitigate some of that
risk but it can't happen if you have an
I clean leader election especially since
we have a hack of one so if you write to
a broker before replicates if something
happens we do have that potential we
haven't seen that but it is a risk that
we do have at the router loss is less
likely duplicates are probably more so
but from a lost perspective
if something happens a routing service
and you exceed your 8 to 24 hour window
you do have that potential
also what we've done there as I
mentioned we've spent a significant
amount of time around monitoring and
alerting
we have threshold of learning for
anything above point one being tenth as
I mentioned the intent of the fronting
Kafka is to buffer the intent of the
router service is to read and move as
fast as possible so as long as there is
no lag between the two or very minimum
you shouldn't lose messages we shouldn't
have that ability but it can't happen
duplicates duplicates where you could
see that happen is if you're trying to
write to sync and what we do is we don't
commit the offset until after we have
written so if the offsets not written
and a job dies will automatically launch
a new one and so it'll read from the
previous offset and so you may get
duplicates we do provide ague it so you
can't be dupe at the sink level
duplicates is not as big of a problem as
I mentioned we can de doop
so more numbers average latency x' for
our s3 sink it's three seconds about a
second for our real-time branch for
stream processing elasticsearch there is
some back pressure there so we are able
to deliver messages a lot faster then
elasticsearch can handle and so we do
have some back pressure and so you're
about 400 seconds percentile lies like I
said I'll share all this stuff I want to
get to more questions
all right there you go
so alerts if we're dropping more than 1%
of messages will alert on that lag as I
mentioned from the routing perspective
is really important so it's a point one
consumer stuck on partitioned
dashboarding very important what we do
is we provide multiple views for people
so as this is our general view for
producers or consumers you can see data
flow it provides kind of a 10,000 foot
you can drop down you can see what's
going on by topic by app what's the loss
what are your throughput rates
internally we track slightly different
things one of the things that we're
building is people to be able to do
self-service data streams when you get
that you'd automatically get your
integrated monitoring all your
dashboarding for people so really kind
of prioritizing the visibility this is
actually pretty interesting it's a
visualization of our environment and
fortunately or unfortunately for this
demo or this talk everything was green
but the intent of this is it provides us
visibility into our environment and we
quickly can see the health of our
clusters and we can do a table form or
chart so for example there trace
annotations health was 99.5 3 but these
will change colors depending on the
health and so it allows us quickly to go
through a large environment and be able
to identify things that are misbehaving
so next steps for what we're doing
self-service tools that touched on it a
bit through this talk better management
for people that are interested or
running these environments please reach
out we're always happy to talk with
people about what they're doing how they
solve problems on the routing layer we
need a more capable control plane Avro
we talked about the other two big things
that we're working on
this year are providing a messaging as a
service general purpose messaging the
service for the rest of the company if
you look at the pipeline there's
multiple steps and so what we're gonna
end up doing is providing the ability
for people to do pub/sub but have that
as a service
the other one is stream processing as a
service so there's right now a few
different technologies out there what
we're trying to solve ultimately is a
multi-tenant
system where people could submit their
jobs they don't have to worry about the
underlying technologies I may want to do
a join and a filter I may want do some
computation and so you have variants in
what those workloads look like so we're
gonna build a general-purpose stream
processing environment for people any
time for questions or did I talk the
entire way alright any questions so
Samsa works really well with Kafka and
part of what we need and a routing
service is the ability to checkpoint
handle back pressure well because we're
trying to do at least once and so we
looked at spark streaming the problem
with spark streaming at the time and
that was earlier versions is it didn't
handle back pressure and from a scale
perspective
like I said we're processing a trillion
messages right now and so we have worked
with the community the spark community I
believe either the one in five or one
six was supposed to have back pressure
work done
we are gonna we are evaluating it for a
stream processing mantis or in-house
stream processing framework there's
right now a lot of use cases that are
using mantis so so yeah I think there's
four routing we had very specific
latency and SLA requirements and Sam's a
fit that profile really well
thank you much